SEAN HANNITY WITH MORE.
♪ ♪
WELCOME TO "HANNITY" AS THE
DEMOCRATS ARE GOING OVER THE
CLIFF POLITICALLY, DESTROYING
THEMSELVES, OTHERWISE WHAT WE
SEE TONIGHT IS TO CULMINATION OF
THE PATHETIC SO-CALLED
RESISTANCE AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IT IS BACKFIRING BIG TIME.
LAWMAKERS ARE SET TO VOTE ON
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT.
IT IS THE LAST MEANINGLESS STEP
IN WHAT HAS BEEN JUST THE
BASELESS POLITICAL SMEAR AGAINST
THE PRESIDENT.
THREE YEARS DO-NOTHING DEMOCRATS
THE LATEST CHAPTER IN WHAT HAS
BEEN DESPERATE, DISHONEST
NONSTOP EFFORT TO UNDO A DULY
ELECTED PRESIDENT AND TAKE THE
PRESIDENT DOWN TO THE WILL OF
HIS SUPPORTERS.
WE, THE PEOPLE, AND LIKE EVERY
OTHER ATTEMPT TO DESTROY
PRESIDENT TRUMP IT IS ON A PACK
OF LIES BY THE PARTISAN HACKS
THAT CAN NEVER BE TRUSTED.
THE INDIVIDUALS ADVOCATING FOR
THIS MADNESS IMPEACHMENT WERE
THE VERY SAME PEOPLE PUSHING THE
RUSSIA, RUSSIA, RUSSIA COLLUSION
HOAX.
THEY WERE WRONG, FOR SEPARATE
INVESTIGATIONS DEAD WRONG,
MUELLER REPORT, NO COLLUSION.
AND TONIGHT WE WILL DETAIL ALL
OF THEIR LIVES, LIVE THEIR
CORRUPTION COME ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS BEHIND THIS.
WE START WITH A HERO AT THE
DEEP STATE, THE SUPER PATRIOT
HIMSELF WHO WON'T COME ON THIS
PROGRAM JIM COMEY.
HE HAS BEEN LYING DECEIVING AND
FORMED THE VERY BASIS OF THE
RUSSIA HOAX.
WHAT WE NOW KNOW, EVERYTHING WE
REPORTED TO END TWO AND A HALF
YEARS DEAD ON ACCURATE.
THE FALL OF 2016, COMEY SIGNED
UP ON THE FIRST FISA WARRANT
APPLICATION, AGAINST
CARTER PAGE.
ONE STEP, TWO-STEP, PAGE AND
THEN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
TRANSITION AND AS
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR SAID DEEP
INTO THE TRUNK PRESIDENCY, HE
SIGNED THAT APPLICATION PURITY
SIGN THREE OF THEM ULTIMATELY.
HE SWORE THAT THE MATERIAL
PROVIDED WAS TRUE AND ACCURATE
ON THE TOP OF A PFIZER
APPLICATION IT SAID VERIFY AND
IT WAS UNVERIFIABLE, THE
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
INFORMATION WAS HILLARY CLINTON
DIRTY DOSSIER.
THAT WAS THE FIRST OF MANY
REPULSIVE LIES THE APPLICATION
WE NOW KNOW RELIED ON A SINGLE
SOURCE, SECONDHAND INFORMATION
FROM CHRISTOPHER STEELE PAID BY
THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN AND THE
DNC.
AND COMEY'S FISA APPLICATION
ADMITTED WHAT THEY KNEW THAT
CLINTON PAID FOR THE MATERIAL.
AND IT ALSO ADMITTED THE
MATERIAL WAS NOT VERIFIED WERE
COOPERATED.
OH, WELL, COMEY FISA APPLICATION
ADMITTED CHRISTOPHER STEELE
POLITICAL BIAS AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT.
THERE WERE NUMEROUS WARNINGS HE
HAD NOT TO USE THIS INFORMATION
AND SUBSEQUENT RENEWALS
SUBMITTED BY COMEY OMITTED
PRIMARY SUB SOURCE, THE SUB
SOURCE, THE ONLY SOURCE NOT EVEN
A SOURCE.
HE DESCRIBED HIS OWN EVIDENCE AS
THE RUMORS HEARSAY SPECULATION
ACCRUED BAR JOKE.
AND ADMITTED THE SUB SOURCE EVEN
QUESTIONS STEELE CREDIBILITY.
WOW AND HE ADMITTED STEELE
DOUBTED THE SUB HORSE.
AND STREET APPLIED, STRAIGHT UP
LIED ABOUT CARTER PAGE AND HIS
CONNECTION TO THE CIA.
ONE OF COMEY'S LAWYERS CHANGE
THE DOCUMENT TO REMOVE THE FACT
THAT PAGE, WELL, WAS A SOURCE
FOR THE CIA BUT INSTEAD SAID WAS
NOT A SOURCE.
REMEMBER, COMEY TOLD US ALL IN
THE CLAIMS OF FISA ABUSE WAS
JUST UTTER NONSENSE.
THIS IS A LIE WHAT WE ARE ABOUT
TO SHOW YOU.
LOOK.
>> TOTAL CONFIDENCE THAT THE
FISA PROCESS WAS FOLLOWED AND
THAT THE ENTIRE CASE WAS HANDLED
IN A THOUGHTFUL, RESPONSIBLE WAY
BY DOJ AND THE FBI.
I THINK THE NOTION FISA WAS
ABUSED AS NONSENSE.
>> Sean: NONSENSE YET ANOTHER
LIKE COMEY KNEW IT WAS GARBAGE
AND UNVERIFIABLE RUMORS AND
SPECULATION AND HE WAS WARNED
MULTIPLE TIMES.
AND EVEN CHRISTOPHER STEELE
UNDER OATH WHEN HE HEARD THIS HE
SHOULD HAVE GONE BACK.
I HAVE NO IDEA OF ANY OF IT IS
TRUE.
THAT IS WHY HE REPEATEDLY DENIED
THAT IT WAS USED WITH THE BULK
OF INFORMATION IN THE FISA
APPLICATIONS THAT WE NOW KNOW
ALSO WAS A LIE.
THAT MEANS DEVIN NUNES WAS RIGH
RIGHT, AND THAT MEANS GRAHAM WAS
RIGHT AND THE SCHIFF SHOW, HE
LIED REPEATEDLY TOO.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU CALL THE DOSSIER
UNVERIFIED, SALACIOUS.
WHY DID YOU USE THAT FOR THE
FISA COURT FOR CARTER PAGE?
NO ONE USED IT BUT YOU LEAD WITH
IT, BULK OF THE FISA APPLICATION
DEALS WITH THE DOSSIER.
WHY?
>> THAT IS NOT MY RECOLLECTION,
BRETT.
I DON'T KNOW IF THE FISA
APPLICATION WAS RELEASED.
MY RECOLLECTION WAS IT WAS PART
OF MOSAIC FACTS THAT WERE LAID
BEFORE THE FISA JUDGE TO OBTAIN
A FISA WARRANT.
>> THERE WAS A LOT MORE THAN THE
DOSSIER AND FISA APPLICATION?
>> MEANT ADDITIONAL MATERIAL
ABOUT PAGE AND WHY AN AGE IN A
FOREIGN POWER.
AND THE DOSSIER WAS PART OF
THAT, BUT WAS NOT A LIPID OR A
CRITICAL PART OF IT TO MY
RECOLLECTION.
>> Sean: A CRITICAL PART,
BASICALLY IT WAS EVERYTHING.
ANOTHER LIE.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL FINDING
THE DIRTY DOSSIER WAS THAT THE
CENTRAL AND EAST CENTRAL --
ESSENTIAL PIECE OF THE FISA
APPLICATION.
JUST LIKE ANY LIAR, HE COMEY
CANNOT COME TO TRUTH.
>> YOU DON'T SEE A DIFFERENCE OF
A BROADER MOSAIC AND PLAYED AN
ESSENTIAL ROLE IN ESTABLISHING
PROBABLE CAUSE?
>> IT WAS ONE OF A BUNCH OF
DIFFERENT FACTS THAT RESEMBLED
AND APPLIED TO THE COURT.
IT WAS THE ONE THAT CONVINCED
THE LAWYERS THEY HAVE ENOUGH NOW
ADDED TO THE PILE TO GO FORWARD.
>> DID YOU KNOW THAT THE FBI HAD
TALKED TO THE RUSSIAN CONTACT
AND HE SAID WHAT STEELE SAID, HE
HAD TOLD HIM IT WAS NOT TRUE?
DID YOU KNOW THIS?
YOU ARE THE FBI DIRECTOR.
>> FIRST, AGAIN, THE REPORT WILL
SPEAK FOR ITSELF.
I DON'T BELIEVE FBI REPORTED
THAT STEELE WAS DEBUNKED.
THEY DID NOT FIND MISCONDUCT BY
FBI PEOPLE.
HE FOUND MISTAKES AND NEGLIGENT
AN OVERSIGHT.
>> NO, NO, NO.
KEVIN KLEINSMITH REPORTED FOR A
FEDERAL INVESTIGATION.
>> RIGHT BUT THAT HAS NOT BEEN
RESOLVED AND CHANGING AN EMAIL
TO A PARTNER ON THE TEAM.
>> Sean: IN CASE YOU ARE
WONDERING, COMEY IS NOT HAVING A
PSYCHOTIC BREAK FROM REALITY BUT
LYING LIKE USUAL THROUGH HIS
TEETH.
FOX NEWS LEGAL ANALYST
GREGG JARRETT IN HIS WITCH HUNT
WITH A SLICE OF THE TIP OF THE
ICEBERG.
FIRST, AS FBI DIRECTOR LOOK AT
THIS, COMEY REPEATEDLY ASSURED
DONALD TRUMP THAT HE WAS NOT A
SUSPECT IN THE COUNTER AND TELL
INVESTIGATION OF RUSSIA, A LIE.
THE SPRING OF 2018, COMEY
CLAIMED HE STILL HAD NO IDEA WHO
FUNDED THE STEELE DOSSIER.
LIFE.
BEFORE HE WAS ULTIMATELY FIRED,
COMEY TOLD THE PRESIDENT, HE
DOESN'T LEAK AND HE DOES NOT DO
WEASEL MOVES.
THAT WAS A LIE TOO.
IN FACT, COMEY LEAKED MEETINGS
AND CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
AND SPECIAL COUNSEL HOROWITZ IN
THIS CASE, THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
REFERRED HIM TO THE DOJ.
REMEMBER, CRIMINAL PROSECUTION
OVER LEAKING AND LACK OF CANDOR.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, THERE IS A REAL
HUMAN COST TO ALL OF THESE
LIES.
THIS IS THE PREMIER
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY AND THE
ENTIRE WORLD.
THIS ENTIRE RUSSIA WITCH HUNT
THAT PUT THIS COUNTRY THROUGH
NEARLY THREE YEARS OF,
CARTER/PAIGE'S REPUTATION
UTTERLY DESTROYED COME ILLEGALLY
SPIED ON, CIVIL LIBERTIES
VIOLATED, HIS CIVIL RIGHTS
DIDN'T EXIST, CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS, NONEXISTENT.
OP-ED BY LAW PROFESSOR WITH AND
TRULY AN TO CARTER PAGE DETAILS
THE RECKLESS NONSTOP SMEAR OF A
PRIVATE CITIZEN ALL BECAUSE OF
COMEY'S FRAUDULENT FISA
APPLICATION.
LET'S NOT FORGET ABOUT
ATTORNEY GENERAL MICHAEL FLYNN
AND WHAT HE DID TO A 33 YEAR
VETERAN.
AS PART OF COMEY'S DECEITFUL
INVESTIGATION, WHAT DID HE DO?
HE BRAGS, FIRST TO
ANDREW MCCABE, NO YOU DON'T NEED
A LAWYER.
BUT HE BRAGS, JAMES COMEY BREADS
AND SETS UP AN AMERICAN WAR
HERO.
I WOULD NEVER DO THIS OR TRY
THIS AND THE BUSH OR OBAMA
YEARS.
I WOULDN'T EVER DO THAT, WATCH
THIS.
>> YOU LOOK AT THIS WHITE HOUSE
NOW AND IT IS HARD TO IMAGINE
THE FBI AGENTS BUT HOW DID THAT
HAPPEN?
>> I SENT THEM.
[LAUGHTER]
SOMETHING I PROBABLY WOULDN'T
HAVE DONE OR MAYBE HAVE GOTTEN
AWAY WITH IN A MORE ORGANIZED
INVESTIGATION, A MORE ORGANIZED
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
GEORGE W. BUSH ADMINISTRATION,
FOR EXAMPLE OR OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
BOTH OF THOSE ADMINISTRATIONS
THERE WAS PROCESS SO THE FBI
WANTED TO SEND AGENTS INTO THE
WHITE HOUSE ITSELF TO INTERVIEW
SENIOR OFFICIAL, YOU WOULD WORK
THROUGH THE WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL.
THERE WOULD BE DISCUSSIONS,
APPROVALS, AND IT WOULD BE
THERE.
AND I THOUGHT EARLY ENOUGH, LIT
SENT A COUPLE OF GUYS OVER.
>> Sean: OAK MY WOULDN'T DO
THESE IN THESE OTHER
ADMINISTRATIONS.
IS THIS THE HIGHER LOYALTY THAT
YOU CLAIM TO POSSESS, JIM?
BECAUSE IS THAT HOW YOU TREAT A
33 YEAR VETERAN OF THIS COUNTRY,
SERVED IN COMBAT, JIM.
THAT JUST SHOWS YOU TO BE SO
DECEPTIVE, NARCISSISTIC AND
YEAH, YOU ARE A LIAR.
JIM COMEY ALSO SIGNS A FISA
APPLICATION VERIFIED
OCTOBER 2016.
CLOSE TO TRUMP TOWER 2017.
IT IS SALACIOUS BUT UNVERIFIED
PRESIDENT-ELECT.
LIGHT AGAIN ANY SIGNS TWO MORE
FISA FISA APPLICATIONS.
HE LIES.
AND THE IRONY OF ALL OF THIS
ATTORNEY GENERAL FLYNN, NOT
COMEY WHO FACE IS BEHIND BARS
FOR LYING WHEN THE FBI DIDN'T
EVEN THINK HE WAS LYING.
BUT THEY ARE GOING AFTER HIS
KIDS AND HE GOES BANKRUPT.
OH MELISSA YOU WILL PROSECUTE MY
SON OR FALL ON THE SWORD.
I AM SHOCKED AT GENERAL FLYNN'S
DECISION BUT WITHOUT A DOUBT
COMEY PLAYED A CENTRAL ROLE OF
THE WEAPONIZATION OF THESE MOST
POWERFUL TOOLS THAT WE CAN TRUST
TO OUR GOVERNMENT AND THEY
TURNED THEM AGAINST WEEK, THE
PEOPLE.
HE DIDN'T ACT ALONE.
LET'S SEE WHAT FORMER CIA
DIRECTOR JOHN BRENNAN, AND
NOTORIOUS LIAR, WHAT ROLE HE'S
PLAYED IN ALL OF THIS.
I CAN'T WAIT TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF THE FACT.
ACCORDING TO MULTIPLE SOURCES,
HE STRONGLY ADVOCATED FOR
HILLARY CLINTON'S BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR DIRTY DOSSIER TO BE
INCLUDED IN THE OFFICIAL UNTIL
ASSESSMENT.
TIME WILL TELL.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL HOROWITZ
CONFIRMED THIS FACT IN HIS
REPORT BECAUSE 2017 WE DO KNOW
THIS.
BRENNAN CLEARLY LIED TO CONGRESS
WHEN HE SAID THE EXACT OPPOSITE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU KNOW IF EVER RELIED ON
THE STEELE DOSSIER AS PART OF
ANY COURT FILINGS?
APPLICATIONS?
PETITIONS, PLEADINGS?
>> I HAVE NO AWARENESS.
DID THE CIA RELY ON IT?
>> NO.
>> WHY NOT?
>> BECAUSE IT WASN'T PART OF THE
PURPOSE OF INTELLIGENCE
INFORMATION THAT WE HAD.
IT WAS NOT IN ANY WAY USED AS A
BASIS FOR THE UNTIL ASSESSMENT
THAT WAS DONE.
IT WAS NOT.
>> Sean: JUST WONDERING WHAT
PROSECUTING DURHAM AND ATTORNEY
BAR NO ONE UP A LOT THAT WE WILL
LEARN IN THE DAYS AND WEEKS
AHEAD APPEAR AT THE CIA DIRECTOR
USED IMPORTANT STATUS TO PUSH
BASELESS, HARMFUL CONSPIRACY
THEORIES AGAINST PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES REPEATEDLY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I THINK HE IS AFRAID OF THE
PRESIDENT OF RUSSIA.
>> WHY?
>> ONE CAN SPECULATE AS TO WHY
THE RUSSIANS MAY HAVE SOMETHING
ON HIM PERSONALLY THAT THEY
COULD ROLL OUT AND MAKE HIS LIFE
MORE DIFFICULT.
CLEARLY, I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT
TO IMPROVE RELATIONS WITH
RUSSIA.
BUT THE FACT HE HAS HAD THIS
ATTITUDE TOWARDS MR. PUTIN HAS
NOT SAID ANYTHING NEGATIVE ABOUT
HIM, CONTINUES TO SAY TO THE
MEDIA HE HAS SOMETHING TO FEAR.
>> Sean: LIES, DECEPTIONS,
HOAX, CONSPIRACY THEORIES,
RUMORS, SPECULATION, CONJECTURE.